mais michel déon ce qui est avec nous ce
soir
vite en irlande qui est aussi il faut le
dire une terre qui connaît actuellement
la violence mais il n'est pas venu et je
crois nous parler des landes il est
surtout venu pour son livre qui est
intitulé un taxi mauve alors michel déon
on a envie un peu de vous connaître
parce qu'on vous a un peu perdu il ya
quelques années vous êtes allez vous
installer en grèce vous avez quitté la
france
et puis après la grèce maintenant c'est
l'irlande
est-ce que pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
quitté la france
je n'ai pas de raisons particulières des
quitté la france il faut bien vivre kg
par vous pouvez vivre à paris vous
pouvez vivre hors de paris vous pouvez
vivre à l'étranger
nous sommes qu'un écrivain et
particulièrement en et 15 en français
mais quitte jamais son pays lorsqu'il
luc 120 à l'étranger et qu'il continue à
s'exprimer en français
j'ai choisi la grèce pendant un long
moment parce que ces paysages m'avait
particulièrement frappée parce que
j'aime le peuple grec
ensuite j'ai été amené à la suite de
circonstances diverses à partager ma vie
entre le la grèce et l'irlande
si bien que je vis actuellement
peut-être six mois en grèce et six mois
en irlande
c'est agréable le nom à me je ne
prétends pas le contraire je ne cherche
pas à me faire plaindre
non je crois que même c'est assez
confortable pour un écrivain parce que
l'irlande est un pays magnifique la
grèce est un pays magnifique
tous les deux ont des pays admirable à
la fois par leur beauté naturelle est à
la fois par la qualité de leur peuple au
fun qui tous les deux m'intéresse
profondément parlez nous un peu désir
landes et je crois que vous aimait
beaucoup les irlandais au oui j'étais
amené à laisser son nom votre livre en
tout cas à wind absolument aucun doute
je ne le cacherai pas je les aime
et les haines infiniment ce sont des
êtres parfaitement naturel possédée par
un amour profond à une sorte de deux
génies de l'humour que nous ne
connaissons pas ici dîner a rien à faire
avec l'humour anglais qui n'est pas un
humour cruel
c'était humour généreux à continuer une
histoire irlandaise
oh mon dieu il renaît la franc
complètement la ruelle à contre-pied la
radio je ne suis pas un raconteur
d'histoires cgt a raconté l'histoire
d'une trente années 80
c'est une histoire qui vous est arrivé
qui pour vous incarniez irlande si ça
vous vient à l'esprit sinon passera non
non non il ya beaucoup de l'histoire
irlandaise que l'on peut raconter ce
sont les histoires qui vous arrive tous
les jours dans les tables dans les
tabous il se vit la vie de l'irlande
parce que l'irlande vit peu dans les
maisons elle vit beaucoup à l'extérieur
je crois que le meilleur se serait de
vous renvoyer à un écrivain irlandais
chatel vandenbiesen qui a été jouée en
france d'ailleurs dont on a joué dont
jean louis barrault et madeleine renaud
ont joué l'otage qui est une pièce
admirable en fait qui est une pièce à la
fois sur la révolte de lire l'ordre sur
les otages enfin sûrement une situation
le ster de la colonie anglaise au nord
de l'irlande
ces économies qui un jour je l'espère
sera réunie à la république d'irlande
une avance très vite et priori très loin
enfin j'ai un parti pris mais nous avons
eu quelques parties tri se serait su
pourquoi pas celui là je crois que
j'aime les irlandais le matin on m'a
posé la question on a dîné
ce sont des primitifs et je digère 4
beaucoup je crois que ce ne sont pas
d'être imités qui je crois que ceux qui
sont acharnés à augmenter la production
dans un pigeon des primitifs et que les
vrais positifs sont ceux qui ont
précisément le goût de sauver leur vie
de que sauver leur vie intérieure est de
sauver leur indépendance de ne pas céder
qu'est ce que c'est comme si on vous
pose la question d'un journaliste le
taxi mauve c'est aussi cette animation
du gala très bollywood est aussi un très
joli sur la chasse
il ya d'ailleurs énormément de scènes de
chasse il ya une description
parfaitement eux précise merveilleuse
poétique de la chasse à la bécasse des
chiens des setter irlandais des
labradors qui vont chercher des canards
vomit des étangs gelés et en impression
en lisant ce livre que vous avez écrit
en même temps des grands traités de
chasse à écouter cette dérive et le
sujet non c'est parce que je suis
passionné par des choses par la
gastronomie et la chasse et la ligue
radio de temps
si nous parlons des relents ne l'ont pas
parler de gastronomie sa joie antilles
par les eaux aux bécanes va et vient
absolument strictement rien les deux
chaînes fois en haut de la chasse à
l'ours tout à fait une autre histoire
qui prend en effet d' rien il s'agit de
quelque chose ou l'aneth engagé tout
entier où l'on retrouve un certain
nombre de vertus naturelles où il
retrouve un logo de la chasse le goût de
la lutte les vous de la ruse
c'est un pays dans lequel on peut encore
se livrer si vous voulez à la chasse non
pas comme un massacre absurde ignoble à
labathude quelque chose digne abus mais
vraiment
les deux presque d'égal à égal j'allais
des ce n'est pas tout à fait exact
puisque l'on a un fusil famille est
l'élément company nous mangeons de steak
tous les jours donc il faut pas
s'apitoyer inutilement sur la vie des
oiseaux les oiseaux sont très nombreux
on peut tuer quelques-uns n'ont mangé
quelques instants mais aussi des chevaux
1 ne serait ce que du bonus
nous allons bientôt mon dieu mais
d'accord vous dire quand même pour
éclairer un peu les téléspectateurs je
crois pouvoir expliquer d'abord le titre
du lisey que le taxi mots c'est
l'histoire d'un jeune homme d'un jeune
américain d'origine irlandaise qui
retrouve un peu ses origines dans une
vieille propriété de famille sans
électricité sans eau
mais avec le téléphone quand j'aime et
qui chasse qu'il retrouve une espèce de
vie naturel et puis qui est replongé
dans des aventures à ces normes sont
sincèrement le du terme un peu comme
dans joyce dans sage parce que ses
soeurs viennent me voir il y en a une
qui est une grande actrice et une
princesse un petit plus est avec un
brass d'europe centrale est relancé dans
le jet set et il arrive à ses
personnages des aventures parfaitement
rocambolesque mais qui ont une espèce de
dimension fantastique et est ce que ce
fantastique là précisément est pas un
vendredi 13 irlandais ce que va ici de
s'en arrêter là les personnages de votre
lit site sans arrêt joy parle sans arrêt
de sage de bananes bnd grand écrivain
irlandais mais le fantastique énorme là
dedans avec un peu des fantômes
l'histoire de la maison très père par
exemple où les personnages se change en
chien est superbe et enfin deux équipes
sont fantastiques anglais mais qui est
un fantastique drôle fantastique joyeuse
fantastique gigantesque oui mais ça
c'est très naturel vous savez il ya des
terres qui inspira particulièrement il
ya des terres qui vous donnent de
l'imagination
or la terre irlandaise est une terre un
peuplé de fantômes les fantômes
irlandais sont célèbres dans toute la
littérature qui consacrait
d'innombrables livres
or si vous voulez les fantômes font
partie de l'imagination landaise et les
fois le rocambolesque fait partie du
paysage
cet index est un visage si nu si naturel
6,6 dépourvu si vous voulez de deux
civilisations par moments mais il m'est
arrivé de mille fois de me trouver au
bord d'un lac cerné de darbres le
regarder ce pays rage et de me dire mais
il ya un million d'années ce paysage
était exactement comme il est
aujourd'hui je m'attends toujours à voir
sortir d'un lac et le nozer à diplodocus
et dire mon dieu pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
ne sort pas pourquoi on se dit pourquoi
ne se montre pas en deux temps avant
qu'on voit en effet sortir un monstre un
monstre qu'on ne voit presque plus qui
sont des loutres puisque les vitres ont
été chassés de toute l'europe
le tout d'un coup un monstre apparaît
c'est une loutre et se tape c'est une
évocation fantastique vous vous croyez 1
millions d'années en arrière
or si vous voulez les caractères dans
une telle situation trouvée ni une
liberté d'expression qu'ils ne trouvent
plus dans d'autres contextes pour
dernière question que je voudrais poser
à michel vion si vous le permettez parce
que le temps tourne malheureusement
c'est votre prochain livre
est-ce qu'il tournera autour de
personnages il vendait aussi en écoute
et non je ne pense pas que ça va on
épuise certains sujets j'ai beaucoup
vécu un regret j'ai fait deux ou trois
livres sur la grèce je vais beaucoup
évoqué la grèce maintenant j'ai beaucoup
évoqué l'irlande la prochaine fois je
voudrais certainement autre chose
vous croyez que vous allez quitter
l'irlande vers l'idée d'habiter ailleurs
je n'en ai pas idée vous comprendrez
pourquoi se fixer une règle de vie alors
qu'on est un écrivain qu'on est libre
qu'on peut se promener partout
donc on peut s'intéresser à tous 3 vous
l'avez dit l'écrivain doit être libre
absolument intégralement
[Musique]